i come from a small town i'm used to
everybody knowing everything anyway
and i don't know i feel like if you're
hiding something there must be something
wrong with it like and
and there's nothing wrong with anything
life just kind of happens and it takes
turns that you don't expect and
um and are sad you know deeply about
what is your favorite part about being
back together again this season
i personally don't know about gwen i
love doing this show
with another female on in the chair as
well i think it's
i think the you know the energy is is
exciting
and i think with the four of us too we
are all so different musically
that i think it's actually very
interesting and i think you know
um representation is really important um
and so it's it's really cool
like to have you know the the rocker
skull
like and she's done papa dance and then
you have john in the army soba pop world
and you have blake in the country world
me and my world like so i think it's i
think that that's really important first
of all
like not male or female just i think
it's cool musically
and then secondly you know like i said i
love having
another female i've done it with all the
guys and it's cool whatever i grew up
with
a lot of guys around me but like i i
like having the the female energy
to kind of bounce off of i think it's
i'm a girls girl like i have a lot of
girlfriends so like i
obviously am welcoming of that so
awesome what about you gwen
well everybody knows how easy it is to
be around kelly
you know she's so much fun and she's
smart
and i've learned a lot from her on the
show um
as well but i think just i just think
it's really fun now that i know her that
that much better like to be on the show
it feels is with the circumstances being
so undone there's no
audience there's way less people on set
it feels super intimate and we all know
each other so well now that it just
it feels like you have zero um awareness
of the cameras it's kind of like we're
just all
friends hanging out and doing the show
and we all know how lucky we are but
i think now that i know kelly is as good
as i do it just feels so comfortable and
fun like it's like being with
a girlfriend like before you got on
we're just chatting like and it's like
that
on set now we're talking oh my god
wow freaking out right now you are
incredible
america's gonna fall in love with you so
good and we can't wait to see you guys
back on set
obviously look we love to see y'all get
out of your chairs
get a little feisty with each other with
the contestants
hug on each other hug on the contestants
how is covid
impacting that dynamic for the show it
is
but i feel like we miss it of course um
but there's just we have to just
restrain ourselves and we've
had we just kind of got used to it
pretty quickly i think
um just it's the way it is right now and
we're it's it's we're just still lucky
to be there so we're just dealing with
it you know what i'm saying but
um i do miss giving kelly a little
squeeze that's for sure
it is bulldog like it you know out of
the four of us
obviously gwen and blake are on it
they're their own little pod so
um what's cool for even america to get
to see some
form of normalcy is you know while john
and i can't really do that
blake and gwen can you know hug and play
and fight and like be
playful and and it's okay and they're
allowed to do that you know so i think
you know while it sucks for everyone to
have to watch everybody be so distant
and it kind of gets a little cold
um at least with this show it's it's
kind of cool because you get
some form of it and i think just
visually
like america getting to see that and it
looks like
some kind of normal visual you know
thing that we were seeing beforehand
i think that's really cool actually it's
just so crazy
you guys both noticed that like we were
watching like my son was watching rad
that was that playing bike from the 80s
you watch old movies now or any movies
and you're like oh
they're touching like oh they're they're
getting close they're like she
she coughed and like we're still aware
of these things now it's it's
it's really a bizarre time we're in it
is so bizarre and i mean
look i know with et we're having to do a
tremendous amount of testing are you
guys having to do a lot of testing
yourselves the contestants as well
when give us a run like what are you
guys trying to do on the testing front
it's constant it feels like uh last week
i must have had a test every day or
something um but it makes me feel good
because at least i know that when
i'm i can make other people feel good
knowing that i know i'm clear you know
what i'm saying like even with my dad i
got to hug my dad
yesterday for the first time and my my
dad has
over in the last year and a half lost
almost 100 pounds
and i hugged my dad yesterday after
dinner
and he led me and it was like this
little these ribs and i was like oh my
god i've never i was like shaking
because i
first hadn't hugged him in six months
second of all he was this little skinny
thing
and i'm so proud of him you know he
works so hard um
but anyways yeah that was something he
was trying to consciously do yeah he's
been doing
it um and he's such an inspiration to me
because he's just he's been so focused
on it
and um but yeah the testing thing helps
with that because it makes you feel
safe you know and um i i
i don't mind it at all of course i mean
it's like it
it's almost like oh you know let's all
test and then we can actually hang out
together and not have to think about it
you want to protect yourself and you
want everything that is around you as
well
kelly i gotta say girlfriend you are an
open book you are the real deal
girlfriend but so you can rock the eye
patch one day and the next day you could
be completely
transparent and real with your audience
about some
recent tough times that you've gone
through 2020 has brought a lot of change
also to my personal life
definitely didn't see anything coming
that came um
but what i'm dealing with is hard
because it involves more than just
my heart it involves a lot of little
hearts you know we have four kids and
divorce is never easy
why do you feel like you have to be that
open with your audience
i don't feel like i have to i've never
felt like i have to i mean if anything
i've
fought my entire career just to be me
because
most managers and publicists get nervous
with me um because i am an open book
and labels and people frown upon it
early on
um but i i don't do it for anyone else
honestly
i just i don't know i come from a small
town i'm used to everybody knowing
everything anyway
and i don't know i feel like if you're
hiding something there must be something
wrong with it like and
and there's nothing wrong with anything
life just kind of happens and it takes
turns that you don't expect and
um and are sad you know deeply about
um and i i just felt like i have a
really solid fan base in the sense that
you know everybody i think
they just care they're like oh is she
okay is she okay
and um the interesting thing is it's not
just about
she and i think that's why i wanted to
address it is there's a lot of hearts
involved here
that's the thing that's been kind of
hard to navigate is
i am an open book but at some point i'm
a mama bear more than i
am a person in the public eye so i care
100 more about my children than i do
anything else on this planet so
um that's been the the hard thing of
like yes i'm willing to share
my experience and yes it is the worst i
mean the past few months have been
horribly sad but at the same time
i have to think hmm like what i say
is a domino effect of people's lives and
you know i've had hot conversations with
one of our eldest about how difficult it
is
in the public eye when your parents are
so you know one of them is so prominent
and
and you know having to navigate that for
them is hard
on their heart so i'm just careful also
while being real um but i don't really
try to do that i don't it's like a goal
that i'm like oh i feel like
it i'm that's just who i am we've all
dealt with our own personal struggles
but when you dealt with them as well
um then you go to the voice and you find
your new leading man
you know so what advice have you offered
up to your friend
kelly here in regards to you know this
journey that she's going through i'm not
i'm not an advice giver and nobody
every every situation is going to be
completely unique
and we're all different people um
i think the one thing that we talked
about that we're both
blessed is that we have our music to be
able to have as an outlet and i'm i'm
sure that you know
eventually people are going to hear
kelly's record which i got a sneak peek
at some of the songs i don't know if
they're
the ones that are going to be coming out
at some point but god definitely
uh you know opens a window and a door
just
closes it's true and you know to be able
to be um
heartbroken or sad or whatever it is i'm
sure it's fueling
whatever her purpose is is to be a
songwriter um
and a singer and that will you know
eventually
contribute back into the world and
that's what her whole purpose is for
so we're all tested here on
in this world it's it's all it's all
happening to all of us all the time we
all have to go through
sad times heartache and if you look at
it like
this is a test we all have to go through
this
um that's that's a good way to kind of
get to the other side because
everybody gets to the other side
eventually